I'm mark I am from Washington DC I work
for Microsoft and just kind of there we
go so I'm a technical solution
specialist at Microsoft I focus on the
azure cloud stack for data and AI so
everything that's related to all of our
managed services and our on premises
stuff related to data science analytics
artificial intelligence we're not I help
the federal government folks in the
federal government adopt our platform
and what's been really cool is that
there are actually pockets of the
federal government that are definitely
using our more and more people are using
our and you know it's a lot of fun so
about me just want a disclaimer so I am
affiliated with a bunch of organizations
again Microsoft
so yes data community DC data community
C was started after Harlan moved to DC
we I was working the Armada up then we
started the data science DC meet up
together and over the years grew to over
20,000 people we have a reach of over
20,000 people across different programs
so Jared we have over 20,000 people it
doesn't matter it's 20,000 people let's
see what else I also am an adjunct
professor at Georgetown in a GW I teach
a big data course where I in the Masters
of analytics so I teach students how to
use Hadoop and spark and how to do a lot
of I would call it like systems / DevOps
/ Linux / everything else they don't
teach you in all the other classes and
really help them embrace this idea of
working with computer computing systems
right because it's very different for
you to start up in our session and you
know do read underscore CSV read in a
file do some stuff right CSV back to
working in large-scale systems working
in production environments being able to
interface with other types of code and
things like that so again my opinions
today are my opinions alone and that's
that just a little bit of shout out why
reinvent the wheel
I hate making slides so so I am just
reusing stuff that's publicly available
I have modified some stuff and I have
added
huntin so a shout out to my Microsoft
peers shout-out to Headley I saw em over
there started - Jady Jady there we go
and on that note so let's see
shut hands who has a big data problem
Wow okay all right well that's fine
maybe you'll have it by the end of this
talk who has experience what to do okay
a few of you who has experience park
couple you all right who has a spiritual
scallop okay who loves our okay all
right so the idea of this talk is really
to show you that you have options of
working with big data you know you might
be scared of it especially you know I
know a lot of people work with smallish
data sets and that's fine and you know I
come from doing large-scale data
analytics usually from a business
context that's my background I have a
background in mechanical engineering I
have an MBA yes I'm a data scientist in
an MBA
we're combination but over the last few
years of my career when I started
getting into the our community and doing
data analytics and I started learning
are after running the meetup I really
fell in love with the community and
really started using all these available
tools I started using Hadoop and are
back in 2010 there's still a couple of
Stack Overflow questions from that time
of course JD was a good contributor to
that because he wrote the first PI
simulation on R and Hadoop streaming
like in 2010 that was a lifetime ago but
really the the fact is that the
ecosystem has matured and I know that
for many our users getting into sort of
this big data stack or big data
ecosystem is sort of you know it's sort
of like a little bit of a fear so
hopefully by the end of today I will
take take away those fears and give you
the tools or give you the ideas to go
and let you go and play around with big
data
oh I'm also here to recruit speakers to
the DC media
okay so first light stolen from JD via
Hadley Wickham or vice versa so you know
when we talk about big data or at least
when I talk about big data
it's really you it's really a lot from
the business context where you have a
lot of long data right I think you're a
made URI or Sandra made reference to
like you know clicks and and and blogs
and stuff like that you have a lot a lot
a lot a lot of transactions normally
you're not working with all of it right
you're always aggregating and bucket
again or whatever so the idea of working
with big data you know ten years ago was
probably you know really getting your
big big data into teeny data and then
pulling it out of your cluster loading
it up to R on your local machine or
Python or whatever and kind of doing
your visualizations doing your analysis
whatever so today I think it's the the
story has changed a little bit you know
Big Data still big but you can take it
down to less Big Data because you have
the computing power to be able to work
with individual data sets on relatively
large machines so case in point you know
you can start up a cluster not a cluster
you can start up a single instance on
the cloud that has several gigabytes of
memory and you know do your analysis
there and then but then there's the
other side of it which is it's really
big it's already spread it's already
scattered and how do you work with that
in the old days you would have to kind
of figure out how to extract data from
databases largely assets gigabytes I'm
not nothing to talk about the petabyte
scale I'm keeping it to the you know
hundreds of gigabytes scale here extract
it and figure out how to work with it so
today with the with the advent of the
cloud it's really easy to work with and
there's other tools about it so again
the same idea of the big data that you
most of the time you can take big data
reduce it to a less bigger data set and
then work with it at the times you can't
there are tools for you and and that's
really the focus of this presentation
and the thing is also that today
especially with the advent of IOT
there's a lot of data that's being
generated and streaming all the time so
you have to figure out how to work with
that and that's long data that you have
to aggregate and ingest so a lot of the
work that I've done over the years has
really been about making day to work
finding tools like setting up the right
tools and environments for folks to do
their analytics right because as I said
before it's really different to start up
float up your lap you start up your
laptop download a data set load it into
R do your stuff
save it do a model whatever it's really
different when you're working with large
data sets it's also very different when
you're working in a just in a in a
shared user environment when you're
trying to break down silos you see this
a lot in the federal government but you
also see this a lot in industry which is
every organization within a company or a
reservation in every group has their own
sets of tools their own sets of methods
and I think we're gonna see this theme
over and over today right but the idea
is sending up a analytics environment
for multiple people is not easy so part
of this is also number one knowing the
tools that are available to you and
number two is there also is an aspect of
I'll call it data engineering for a lack
of a better term that you do need to
know and do need to be a little bit
aware of or proficient in to really be
able to take advantage of this ecosystem
so you know this is our working in in
general right and in normal and
large-scale so with take a dataset we
loaded into memory on a single machine
there's been a lot of work over the
years to make the data replication less
expensive and you know thanks to all the
folks in in our studio and the our
community that have taken the you know
the tide of us and all the other tools
that make it a lot easier to work with
but inherently our is single threaded
there's no parallel there's no inherent
parallelism so there's many many ways to
approach this problem
so five years five years ago I don't
think you can see that but why
five years ago we gave a talk in DC
about our for Big Data and there's all
sorts of I know you can't see it but
this is just like a little mind map of
of all different things and the big the
big boys back then were down here like
reap our hype which is on our Hadoop
integration rmr and some of the early
stuff that the revolution analytics team
was working on the xdf revoscaler and
all that stuff today I think the
ecosystem is a little bit different so
you have you know the biggest thing what
I think really makes the reduces the
barrier to entry are these packages
appear so you've got spark R which is
actually part of the spark ecosystem it
actually is built into mainline spark
there is sparkly are a package written
by the our studio folks that really
lowers the barriers to entry for our
users into the spark ecosystem there's
revolution real scale R which is part of
the revolution distribution of R which
is now part of Microsoft and then
there's h2o which is a machine learning
platform for distributed data there's
other other tools right the stuff on so
the stuff on the top is what I'm going
to focus on today the first the first
two actually and then just just so you
know there's also other packages
available if you don't know about them
so there's big memory
there's FF and kind of the 4-h and do
parallel backends which allow you to do
parallel computing on your local machine
taking advantage of multi-threading
I mean multiple cores and or setting it
up and something sorry something like
this where you have
perhaps a cluster of our machines where
you can actually distribute your work
and this is more along the advent of
high-performance computing that's not
what I'm gonna be focusing on today but
this is just good for reference these
are some of the different packages and
distributions and how they you know the
advantages they give you so you know
cran like regular are works on single
machines these other packages gives you
a bit the ability to work on single or
multiple machines or use clusters as the
backend and then then we move on to
spark so so not many people use spark
but are you guys familiar with spark
okay so for those that don't know or for
those to do so spark is an open source
project it's basically a distributed
computing platform for general computing
and it's gotten traction because what it
changed is that it actually uses memory
and/or disk as opposed to just using
disk Hadoop is just a batch process read
and readout which was very effective
when it came out you know got a lot of
folks were using Hadoop back in the day
what's and they still are because Hadoop
is really or Hadoop and MapReduce is
very good for certain kinds of jobs
there are other kinds of tasks where
Hadoop is really not that great and
that's where SPARC I think has really
made a big impact on the large data on
the big data ecosystem so what SPARC
allows you to do is really take
advantage of memory in memory
computations so that works really well
for machine learning where you have to
do multiple passes on your data you know
you can't sometimes you can't do machine
learning in batch mode or if you can but
it's gonna read it once read it a second
time reader to third time and so on and
so on and when your data is in the multi
gigabyte or multi petabyte scale you
have a time problem so SPARC gives you
the capability of doing large-scale
computations it really abstracts a lot
of the cluster management for you and
the these are kind of the building block
the building blocks for SPARC so on the
top you've got the API interface with
spark so SPARC is written in Scala so of
course there's a skylight bi there's a
Python API there's also
our API and in Java Scala and Java are
interchangeable the four building blocks
kind of the the different threads of
spark would it gives you ability to do
so you have sparks equal so sparks equal
gives you the ability of doing
structured data analysis using sequel
like commands then spark streaming is
use you know doing analysis of real time
data as its flowing spark EMA lib so the
the spark team has actually coded a lot
of machine learning algorithms already
that are available for spark you
probably get about 90% of the way there
with what's out there with this with
spark and then graphics is a graph API
on top of spark and then spark is what's
cool about spark is that it gives you
the ability it you can run it on
different kinds of clusters you can run
it on a Hadoop cluster
you can run understand a little spark
cluster you can ran its thing and I know
on a single machine and it lives
alongside Hadoop and MapReduce so spark
are gives you a you know spark art is
built into spark it actually gives you
the ability to interface with the rdd's
which is the Scala Scala's sort of low
level data object or data structure
that's available in spark and then over
the years there's been the development
of higher level API for spark including
spark sequel and the spark data frame
that's where sparkly art comes into the
place I will just jump here so sparkly
what sparkly are allows you to do is it
really allows you to use spark as a
back-end and it really fits in well with
the tidy verse so it just it creates the
connection object for you it translates
tidy code into spark sequel and it runs
stuff in the backend it doesn't do
everything but it gets you I'll say 90%
of the way there and you know your see
you to them so think of it as using our
as a front-end right you're using your
our console whether it is on your local
laptop or it is running on an AR server
on the cloud so your our instance
becomes your interface to the cloud so
that also abstracts the
the fear of dealing with with clusters
and and kind of dealing with all of the
DevOps and like I said data engineering
stuff that that comes attached to that
spark our spark clear what the spark
thank you so I just found this blog post
recently this fellow Edie just kind of
did a comparison of spark barn spark
lair so smart car is part of the spark
distribution it gets installing on
cluster when you install spark as of I
think 1.6 right now Sparks is like 2 2
or 2 3 and then sparkle er is I think
it's at 0.7 but it's it's it's
progressed a lot over the last year and
a half so you know again thanks to the
our studio team and everyone involved
with building all those great tools for
us to use this gives you a high-level
overview of kind of the difference so so
spark are is really meant to interact
more more you can do a lot with both I
think some of them have particular
strengths and weaknesses so spark are
gives you the ability to interact mostly
with the RDD which is the low-level data
structure in spark where a sparkly are
gives you a better way to interact with
the higher level objects which are the
spark data frames one thing I read
that's not necessarily here and and this
is what kind of contradicts is I my
understanding was that running arbitrary
code or user-defined functions was
actually easier to do with spark are
than with sparkly are but and this says
otherwise again I don't know much about
that but the key thing here is this is
the tie diverse compatibility so as you
see here basically you can just write a
deep liar statement you start your I
mean there's the code for starting your
clusters not here but let's say you
start your cluster your interface with
the cluster you create your object and
then you just refer to your table as if
it was a data frame and you can use that
object as part of your tidy code and
then it that gets shipped off into the
cluster in the backend so you know I
guess it's part of the tight universe
now and so one thing I did want to
mention is one aspect of of working with
big data that's really hard is setting
up your entire
you know there are many cloud providers
out there I work for one of them and but
truth be told is one of the challenges
that I I was faced with early on was
really setting up the environment the
right way because it's not just starting
a cluster right you can start a cluster
really easily but if you want to work
with are if you want to work with our
studio if you want to work with all your
our packages there's a really a lot of
DevOps work that's involved there and
before I used a sure I did all that
stuff manually and it was a royal pain
I'm not saying this because I work for
Microsoft I'm saying this because I
truly believe it
the Azure platform really gives you
makes it really easy to work with these
tools so you can actually start up a
cluster with our and our studio already
installed and all you have to do is run
with it so that for for many folks that
don't have that skill set of data
engineering sysadmin DevOps all that
sort of stuff it makes it really really
easy so and we have a whole slew of
tools right you know we have so there's
our there's Microsoft R then there's
revolution R but as you can see it
really fits into the to the Big Data
ecosystem we recently launched the data
BRICS integration with Azure data brakes
are the folks that actually wrote SPARC
the folks behind data bricks are the
folks that rode spark and it's now fully
integrated with the Azure platform and
it's truly amazing it's really a cool
interface because it it's even higher
level interface than using spark or not
Hadoop cluster it's a spark cluster and
this is a platform as a service that
just sort of takes advantage of running
everything for you but like I said I'm
really not trying not to be pitchy
because I'm not but it really makes it
easy to work with and I'm happy to talk
offline about the tools that's and how
to get you folks involved so some
parting shots so don't don't be afraid
of the big data tools that the ecosystem
has evolved there are more options for
you out there you know there's HPC
options there's multi-threading options
their spark options there's Hadoop
options I would encourage you to learn a
little bit about data engineering
leverage in database analytics as much
as you can so you don't have to move
data around just a little bit of synote
a lot of times the examples that are
available online refer to a data set
most of these are open but they're not
readily available so over time I've been
collecting those publicly available data
sets and making them more readily
available you know they're not zipped
they're actually ready to use so I have
- I have a s3 bucket and an azure bucket
with some large data sets including the
New York City Taxi and and others and I
just would encourage you to try Azure as
a platform so please come visit us in DC
if you'd like to speak at DC let me know
we would love to have you so thank you
very much
[Applause]